yeah you had yet another crazy taxi
experience didn't you connor i did
i did i'll send uh oh i wish i could
send you the picture of like the route i
took but i'll
i'll do like a fake like drawing of it
for this because if i show you
actually the route you'll know where
essentially this guy took what should
have been a 10 minute journey yeah
and did it 45 minutes so um
what's up with that but i mean this is
the thing right so
i you know i what happened was is that
this wasn't like a miscommunication
fault or anything because
i didn't tell him where to go the app
tells him where to go because i was
using a ride sharing
app right so yeah literally when he
picks me up he he has to say oh okay
this is where i pick him up this is
where i'm going yeah and then when he
when he you know when he says he's
picked me up it'll tell him
on the thing where to go all right and i
got in the car and i saw where it was
telling him to turn and do all that and
it was yeah well i told him to go all
right
and for some reason this guy just you
know ignored the turn and i was like
okay
whatever like there's a better roof
right maybe he knows
you know because he was like 80 or 90
very very very old yeah yeah he knows
that he knows the streets better than
the maps i'm sure
all right all right that's sure i'm sure
and so then he misses the next turning
and i'm like all right okay this is the
next turning and i'm like okay this is
getting a little weird some local
version
and then and then he like and then he
misses another turning and this is
getting to the point where i'm like all
right this this man is just straight up
going the wrong way so i asked him in
like
terrible japanese i'm like where are you
going and he said um
somewhere in like roppongi yeah which is
like totally no
not where i was going yeah and i was
like oh like literally the opposite
like the opposite way which where i was
going and yeah no no no don't go that
way
go the other way yeah and then he was
like what what where do you want to go
and i i told him where i wanted to go
and he was like
what and i'll show the app and he's like
oh let me put my glasses on i'm like
you're driving without your glasses on
you can't read this and you're driving
i'm like they do this every time every
time i
no this annoys me to death about taxi
drivers here yeah every time
i show them on my phone where they go
they have to put glasses on and i'm like
if you can't read right why are you
driving
why are you driving without these
glasses on like you just what is this
blurs
yeah so he completely goes the wrong way
and i eventually get to like figure out
to explain to him where i want to go
uh and it was just because there was
some weird thing with the address that i
put in why it wasn't quite what i said
it was
but even though the address in the thing
was still correct
but i had to then reconfirm to him that
i was going to the place
where it told him to go yeah which is
like why do you even ask me don't talk
to me just take me where i want to go
are you sure you want to go to the place
you specif you specified this is what i
don't get it i told you where i want to
go yeah
you know maybe you can confirm and i
said yes
what what i'm losing my mind right so
then you know the thing is racking up to
be pretty expensive because this is like
a 45 minute journey it's pretty [ __ ]
expensive especially in tokyo
as well yeah yeah because you know the
journey i was going to take was just 10
minutes and it was supposed to be like
10 15 bucks no but not a big deal yeah
it turned into like a 45 50
ride and i'm like hold the [ __ ] yeah and
also
after i eventually told him where to go
i was pretty stressed out yeah
and now someone i was on yeah i was
trying to watch youtube videos and i was
looking at my phone and then suddenly
the guy just emergency stops
like so i just my [ __ ] bag goes like
flying my water bottle just flying
i'm like yo what the [ __ ] this is like
the best [ __ ]
i was like listen i don't know if you're
going for like the worst taxi speed run
any percent here i don't know what
you're trying to do you're literally
[ __ ] everything up here he's like
dead i was like a gta
he nearly crashed the taxi and he was
unfortunately i couldn't see if it was
his fault or not right
uh it looked like it wasn't his fault so
i
i didn't blame him that but it was also
just you know also just kind of annoying
manchester here playing crazy taxi yeah
he was literally playing crazy talent
and then immediately okay after this as
well i think because then he was
panicked because he was
like he'd taken me wildly off route he'd
nearly crashed the car wildly [ __ ] up
he pretty much [ __ ] up everything a
taxi driver could [ __ ] up yeah
so he started speeding to get me to
where i needed to go
and i did not feel comfortable with this
man speeding he just nearly crashed a
[ __ ] taxi
i was like i asked him and i was like ah
i was like can you go a little in in
japanese yeah could you go a little
slower
and he would and then he panicked he
turned his full head around no no no
no no no no look i'm like hold on i'm
gonna put a glass on to
the speedometer normally normally you
know i normally am fully accepting of
the
that kind of yeah yeah oh yeah okay you
got you he was like
no no no he's getting like 80 on a 50
road
stop no no no no i'm not gonna say
anything i'm not gonna say yeah
and and then i was like i was like this
is the worst [ __ ] taxi ride on my
goddamn right yeah and so
every taxi driver in um in japan has
like their full uh company information
and name and everything on the thing
yeah so i took a picture of it uh and
my phone has the in japan every phone
has to make a noise
you when you take a picture and shutter
so so my phone did that so i
think he heard it i don't know so anyway
he finally got me to where i was you
know one piece i had to like check
myself when i got out the car my life
right
and as i was getting out he like slowly
pulls his wallet out
and i'm like you're trying to try to
bribe me to not complain
is that even legal probably not legal
i think so he was um he didn't he didn't
tell me
uh don't say anything he was right i
think what he was trying to pay the
difference
of what he went over right so it worked
out to be around what he went over
right right so like the fee should have
been like
um like 15 it was like 40. so he gave me
like 30 bucks and i was like
fine you know what i don't want to
complain to your company i don't have to
do that
because i wanted to get my money back
from the companies i was like this is
[ __ ] terrible yeah
i don't know if that's me being a karen
like i just think that i don't want to
get ripped off
no i i mean i don't think it's like
karen to be like i
almost died can i have money yeah yeah i
because i do i hate com
i do not i'll never ever complain about
someone who is doing like a job where
you don't make much money because yeah
i don't feel like no i get it i don't
think you get paid enough
to warrant you know you're losing some
money like
you know if i have if i have problems at
like fast food places i'll never
i'll just be like you know what i it
wasn't great i'll keep it to myself
i'll deal with it i might leave not a
great review but like that's not i won't
be like super harsh
you're not gonna be like where's the
manager that's the british way to do
things right
you know like again you know i don't
want to make someone's life more
difficult than it needs
life is [ __ ] hard enough as it is but
but right there is a certain point where
i'm like
you have done such an awful job where i
think
it's okay for me to want my money back
well yeah of course of course and
i i feel like taxi is understandable
because your life is in their hands
yeah yeah yeah and literally everything
was terrible so i was i was just going
to complain to
the not to his company first i was going
to complain
to uh the uh the app to see if that
because the app can normally just
because he'll still get paid i believe
and then they'll just refund me yeah
which is what i wanted
um because f [ __ ] the multi conglomerate
but instead he just like
took out the yeah he paid me 30 bucks
and i was like sure
so i gave him five stars he
he's like i don't speak any english but
you speak this
you language what i'm saying you know
what i'm saying i was like you know what
i was like
the man's hustling all right
literally bribed a five-star uber review
from you
i was like you know what the man the man
knew that he [ __ ] up big time and he
wanted to try and fix it i respect it
i i don't want to go through this you
don't want to go through this let's just
walk away you don't speak japanese but
you speak the ones
all i wanted was the difference back i'm
happy to pay the taxi fee
i just don't want to be charged like 30
40 extra
i don't know i'm not like i'm not a lot
of fun i'm not a cheap guy
i just don't be ripped off